how hard is it for you not to talk about
anything you're not allowed to talk
about well there's plenty to talk about
like the 2020 race and the the who yell
encore Biden of Joe Biden for example
you like Joe Biden well I think Trump
would beat him like a drum I mean the
guys are like he's a physical and
intellectual lightweight can't see
himself he actually thinks he's
important he's a pompous blowhard he'll
try and provide him fighting oh he can't
seem to keep his hands off of other
people's children no oh that's not a
right-wing conspiracy theory there are
hundreds of pictures and thousands of
feet of video footage of him
inappropriately touching children you
can see they're uncomfortable you can
see their parents are uncomfortable
that's just weird but do you think it's
on these touching kids and appropriately
just being too affectionate like is that
it's sexual yeah I don't know sexual I
don't think so
it's just I look either way you look at
it whether it's women or children
because it's got the same propensity
it's creepy it is creepy I don't think
it's sexual but I do think it's creepy
actually there's footage where one u.s.
senator slaps his hand away from this
from his granddaughter because Joe's
getting a little too handsy so you think
the a real hiccup in Joe Biden's
potential run for presidency could be
that his opponents President Trump for
example may bring up the fact that
there's lots and lots of video of him
uncomfortably touching children and
women it's already being brought up yes
no I have more serious problem nobody's
been a jealous drug warrior than he has
our realities more responsible for
locking up poor people and black people
for the first time nonviolent offense of
possession of small amounts of marijuana
and Joe Biden our prisons are clogged
with poor people and black people who
are subject to far harsher sentences
than rich white guys get who get caught
with cocaine
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]